your brothers and sisters in islam net
from norway are establishing a masjid a
daowa center
this center this masjid this educational
institution will act like a beacon of
light calling the muslims in norway back
to the essence of islam so give
generously and allah azzawajal will give
you even more
[Music]
many of you will be aware of the recent
attack on one salman rushdie an
individual who is an open advocate
against or detractor of
islam and the islamic prophet
ever since that time when he wrote his
book
he and the fatwa was
by the corrupt states of iran
was declared upon him
there was there has been or at least he
has become
an emblematic figure
for the cause of freedom of expression
and speech
and especially
in neoconservative or right-wing
quadrons of particular political
discussion we find
that freedom of speech is juxtaposed
with islamic blasphemy laws for example
or things of that nature or islam and
muslims in general or indeed
muslim reactions to um desecrations of
the sacred symbols of islam so there's
this juxtaposition which we find
uh in the orientalizing type of
literature that we see
in in books in academia and of course on
on the media as well
question is of course is such a thing
even
um appropriate considering the
circumstances now that's what i want to
say is
from as much as i know in america for
example in the uk in the us and much of
the west in fact most of the west we
don't see particular pieces of
legislation which are aimed against
things like blasphemy law
but we don't find the same
free speech absolutists
individuals who are talking about free
speech
and advocating its merits
talk about other things which are in
fact enshrined into legislation for
example of course holocaust denial being
one of them of course we don't
necessarily advocate such a position
just for the record
or
want to antagonize our good friends in
the jewish community
but
if one is truly a free speech absolutist
shouldn't one be lobbying against
with all vociferousness
and vigor shouldn't one be
lobbying against such a law
in any meaningful way
shouldn't we be seeing our twitter feeds
flooded
with messages against those governments
in
europe and elsewhere
that have made holocaust denial
something which is
illegal and a criminal offence shouldn't
we be seeing protests across the streets
of berlin
and london
on such a matter
the reason why we're not seeing it is
because
individuals who are proponents
for
free speech absolutism
usually
or sometimes at least
employ the most terrible
of double standard
now i'm not asking such individuals to
vicariously sympathize with the muslim
cause or islam
in general
but what i am saying is be consistent to
your own cause
when gutless murray himself recently
came
and spoke to my good colleague abdullah
andalusi and friend and mentor and try
to corner him because he is a gutless
coward who cannot and has not responded
to any of our debate offers
in the past
when he
himself had the audacity
to
question
abdullandalusi a figure
whose books are everywhere in most
[Music]
book shops in the west
and at the same time
he tries to restrict the freedom of
speech through the henry jackson society
of muslim speakers that if not a double
standard what could it be
what could it be what is it then if it's
not a double hypocrisy
from you people it's not about freedom
of speech you're liars
you are a liar
and you are all liars it's not about
freedom of speech it is about the
selective use of freedom of speech in
order to inhibit
and derail
and diminish
the rights of muslim people who happen
to be minorities
in western lands that's really what's
going on isn't it
because you don't want to admit that
because you have an ulterior agenda in
fact you need us
more than anything else because we are
the very
community which you need to tell your
children who grow up being in some cases
white supremacists in other cases at
least fierce nationalists against any
ethnic minority outside of themselves
to say this is what you're not
you need us
you need us to be the scapegoat that you
can blame for every mistake that happens
in your life every failure that you have
which is why it's no
it is no
coincidence that most right-wing
far-right individuals like tom robinson
as ilk
are the most uneducated low iq
individuals in all of society
so what i will say is
to conclude as follows my friend ali
dawa has made a very good point in his
videos a very very good point which is
that he said
why do you specialize islam in this
discussion when if the sacred symbols of
other peoples from other faiths as we've
seen with the hindutva
in india
he makes the example of ataturk in
turkey some kurdish leader he mentions
we can go on and on
if you try and desecrate the sacred
symbols of individuals they will the
gangster communities among them will
deal with you my friends
we're not condoning such a thing at all
but that is a reality
we the muslims at 1.8 billion which
represent according to pew will
represent a third of population of the
world
one and three
at least one and four now
you don't think we have gangsters we
have gang muslim gangsters as well
and when you go ahead and attack the
sacred symbols of islam although our
approach is not to do so we can't stop
the gangsters from dealing with you or
anyone else
we can't stop the muslim gangsters
from dealing with you or anyone else
just like if you go to colombia and you
speak about particular cartel
in a specific manner go to their area be
a man and speak about them
you want free speech absolutism don't
just deny the holocaust knock it if
you're a real man and see what happens
to your career
how about
black communities i want to see how
strong you are free speech douglas
gutless murray and others like you
why don't you speak about the black
community in a racially insensitive way
and then go to harlem or detroit and see
what happens to you see if there's any
gangsters there that will slice and dice
you and chew you
don't you dare speak about islam or the
muslims where you cannot and you will
not debate
people like me
or abdullandalusi oh
any of us in a one-on-one environment
with that
i will conclude
the prophet muhammad
when the son of adam dies
all of his good deeds are interrupted
they are finished
except for three things
a continuous charity and a beneficial
knowledge and also a righteous offspring
that makes dua for him your brothers and
sisters in islam net from norway are
establishing a masjid a tawa center and
fulfilling a great portion of this
hadith on your behalf establishing a
masjid to convey the message of islam is
one of the best deeds a muslim can do
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada
in the masjid whenever someone learns
something in the masjid
yes
that will be something that you will
have on your scale
so give generously and allah azzawajal
will give you even more
you